Google is kind of a unique company for me and for, I think, a lot of people that work there.
What Google does is it allows you a fantastic environment to be innovative...
...and to get your product developed really quickly.
It is a very different structure than the rest of the engineering community.
We always really try to avoid bureaucracy...
...so that people can really do what makes sense in their project.
One thing that's great about Google is that you have...
...a lot of autonomy over your product and its directions.
We're encouraged to work on whatever we think is important.
Often, the best ideas come from employees.
At Google, if you come in your first week...
...and you have a good idea on how things should be done...
...and people agree with you in that first week, you can start making those changes.